is eight news now we are in spring break
here for clark county school district
and if you're a ccsd parent and maybe
it's a little bit of a break for you too
getting children up early for school it
is a challenge that's why health experts
are advocating for later school times as
bradley blackburn reports new research
shows it can really benefit the whole
family
[Applause]
high school teacher kelly osuna and her
two teen sons have busy mornings getting
ready for the day but they say it's been
much less stressful since their school
began starting classes later prior to
the time change i had to get them into
before care
and then have enough time to get back to
my job by seven so we were leaving the
house at the very latest
by 6 15. health experts say early school
start times can impact teens learning
and increase risks for obesity and
depression now research from national
jewish health looks at how moving start
times later can be good for the whole
family researchers partnered with a
large district near denver adjusting
middle and high school start times 50 to
70 minutes later what we found was that
these parents were reporting later wake
times similar to their students and an
increase in the amount of sleep that
they were obtaining dr lisa meltzer
authored the study which also found
fewer parents reported feeling tired
during the day researchers say many
middle and high schools begin too early
only about 20 percent of u.s high
schools start at or after 8 30 a.m
that's the time recommended by the
american academy of pediatrics sleep is
important for every aspect of
functioning osuna is grateful to be
getting more sleep she now gets up at
the time she used to leave the house i
noticed such a huge difference
just in
my
mood and my affects when i do get in
front of students in the morning or even
the time that i'm with my children in
the morning and as an educator and mom
she says it's a great way to start the
day
bradley blackburn cbs news